no I don't think the shaman fears the
end because the fearfulness of the end
is its unknowability you know what is
death what is the end of history as long
as you don't know these things become a
screen for the projection of your inner
doubts and fears once you know then it's
possible to return to ordinary life and
live it to the fullest this is why
shamans are often people who have
survived some incredible ordeal or
disease or psychedelic experience so
it's a shift in perspective and it's a
way of relating to the felt presence of
the moment this is very important a
shaman
lives in the moment in a way that we who
are the inheritors of Western
civilization phonetic alphabets and
print culture can't even imagine because
our whole lives are based on such
thoughts as I'll be happy when I I'll
feel better
when
it's always projected into the future
the shaman is somehow able to take the
good and the bad together and come out
of that encounter with a feeling of
optimism and wholeness